hello everyone in a few weeks from now a
new badge of students is going to enter
their first year here at iit kharagpur
similarly across various institutes of
india
students have already either joined or
are about to join
various engineering streams as well as
science streams so i thought this would
be a good time for me to share some of
my experiences
give some pointers dispel certain
misconceptions that students invariably
have at this stage i know i did back
when i was a student uh
about to enter my first year here at iit
kharagpur and i wished at that stage
somebody would sit down with me and help
to clear some of my doubts now that i
have gained certain experiences as an
engineering student first myself and
then as a faculty member over the past
few years
i think i'm in a good position to share
some of my experiences and i think some
of you will find it useful and actually
i got the idea of making this video
after seeing the wonderful response of
so many students
to the video that i had made as a
reaction to the
speaks
so if you look at the comment section so
there are a number of students about to
join their first year who have written
to me uh so i think they'll definitely
find it useful all right so number one
point on the academic side
so
the number one misconception which
students invariably have is that they
are going to join first year and then
they are going to start learning
subjects this is not going to happen
okay in the semester system you do not
learn subjects
you learn courses there's a difference
between the two
so what you do in courses
well in a course what you do is to
actually study the sub the the sequence
the exact sequence of topics which your
professor have
which your professors have selected for
you they've already done this job by
scrutinizing the various books and
selecting and extracting
only the parts which are immediately
relevant for you which are important for
your professional career as well as to
prepare you for your higher studies
so trust them and follow the course
material which have been prepared by
them
this does not mean that you should not
try to learn the subject but that will
come a little bit later
very relevant to this point is that many
students think that they are going to
learn a course by starting from a book
this is absolutely wrong
okay please do not try to study from
books on your own
rather the trick is that
from the sequence of topics which your
professor has
given to you and from the way that he or
she is teaching to you
you first try to learn what he's
teaching what he or she is teaching and
then
only after you have gone through those
parts you go back to your book and try
to study the relevant parts from that
that is the way to study otherwise
you see in a semester system you barely
have 100 days or so
and i am also including the saturdays
and sundays here
so in these 100 days
it is simply not possible to study from
books i'll show you something
this semester i'm teaching mechanics of
solvency because this is not a first
year subject this is a second year
subject but things are more or less the
same
let me show you the books okay
so this is one book
this is another book
and this is another book
and now you cannot see my face
so
you really think you can go through all
these books because we we give maybe one
or two textbooks and then give others as
reference materials you simply cannot go
through all of them it is humanly not
possible
so study only the relevant parts from
the books
next
grades
so
don't let anyone mislead you into
thinking that grades are not important i
know in engineering colleges especially
some of the seniors have this habit of
telling their juniors that grades are
not that important it is completely
wrong do not believe them
okay higher grade is always better
however i will also say that
do not fall into the rat race of
just mindlessly mindlessly chasing
higher grades
okay
that is kind of unhealthy
try to maintain a respectable grade
point average
and
you must also understand that
in reality
some things may always go sideways okay
they'll invariably go sideways in a
particular semester
so if as a result your grade point
average decreases a little bit
it does not mean the end of the world
okay please do not think like that
so this directly ties into the next
advice that i'll give to you is that
be a little bit pragmatic in your
approach
okay what i mean by that is that suppose
in a certain semester or in a certain
subject certain things have gone
sideways sideways means something bad
has happened okay maybe one test or
assignment has gone bad this does not
mean that you just give up i have seen
many many students do this okay
something goes wrong and then they just
give up
this is just foolish
what you need to do if something does go
wrong is to just pick up the pieces and
try to do damage control except the fact
that something has gone wrong okay be an
adult about it
except that something has gone wrong and
try to fix it try to do some damage
control okay if you just give up
it will go from bad to worse and that
bad thing in one subject is start is
going to start affecting your other
subjects and then everything will go bad
in that semester okay and you will
become extremely sad so it's a disaster
don't let that happen do some damage
control
all right
next point is regarding projects so
uh i have seen that many first-year
students they have their like bundle of
energy and they
uh
they try to start doing some projects
some academic projects try to approach
some professors this is not the right
approach
this is not the right approach because
when you have not even completed your
first year you barely know the subjects
okay so the way that we follow in most
of the iits in all the ideas rather is
that the first year curriculum is common
okay you only get to start learning the
departmental subjects properly in the
second year so unless you have gone to
the second year studied the third
semester courses
up to that point you are not well
prepared to take up a proper academic
project so little so have a little
patience until that time comes okay at
the the first year is not the right time
for you to take up a project
okay
there's a special tip for iitns here
you see all of you
and this is common knowledge but i think
i'll be
i'll be remiss if i don't say this
all of you have been kind of academic
stars of your particular batches maybe
it is in school in college
in your coaching center whatever
you have been kind of academic stars
this is going to end once you enter
the iit's
you are no longer going to be the stars
because it's it's a common sense thing
right so all the academic stars have
joined together so everyone is a star
you are nothing special
okay i know it can be kind of i mean sad
to think about it but this is the truth
it's a great privilege that you get to
have as your peers so
uh
so gifted students or capable students
so don't take it as a negative rather
take it as a positive but i assure you
this after all we are all human flesh
and blood
you will feel sad a little bit okay that
you are no longer that that you no
longer have that special status
which you had earlier in school
okay but please try
to not
to let not that affect you
next is regarding various societies or
student groups
uh
i've seen that many students
they
mindlessly chase
after this
after various after after this goal of
joining various societies or student
groups this is not correct
okay it is absolutely necessary for you
to do some activity
in your engineering or science which is
not fetching you marks it is important
to do such kind of activity but at the
same time
if you try to join this you're trying to
join that also you're trying to learn
that also you are going to spread
yourself too thin
you have only a finite amount of time in
your hand
finite amount of energy also
so you should not be spreading yourself
too thin such that the
work that you are doing both in your
curricular activities as well as your as
well as in your co-curricular activities
okay
they get affected in quality
so more than the quantity and the
variety of things that you do try to be
really really good excellent in whatever
little you do that will carry far more
weight
okay
another important thing is that you
should not be shy to ask for help
now i when i was in my first year i was
extremely introverted
okay
i'm still introverted i've just learned
how to fake it a little bit now so
there's that but
uh you absolutely need to ask for help
when you need help
okay so
uh next point is on the social side and
this is very very important okay please
don't close the video just because i've
stopped talking about the academic and
the student group side of things this is
important
on the social side okay
you have to start making friends
i mean seriously good friends
now
uh when i say like this
please don't think of it like some kind
of a business arrangement okay that is
not going to work of course
at the same time
you will never be able to have good
friends
if you're not proactive about it you
have to seek out
friends
and let me tell you this
uh
it is good to have the kind of friends
who you
you like to hang out with but at the
same time you also need to have friends
from whom you can learn something
okay it is not only just the professors
from whom you are going to learn rather
you are also going to learn a lot i mean
in fact a lot of lot of the things from
your peers from your seniors
so try to make some very good friends
there's a very special point i would
like to mention here is that
when you are making these kinds of
friends
try to
make
friends from different kinds of circles
okay so that your mind and your
development
by connection with those friends is not
just one-dimensional okay maybe have
some friends who are good in sports
maybe have some friends who are good on
the cultural side of things maybe they
know how about music about uh about
various cultural things maybe they're
good in writing or or reading
maybe you could pick up some things from
them maybe some someone is very good in
electronics kind of things or in
programming
even if you don't engage in those
activities yourself you will definitely
learn some things from them
that's a valuable thing
okay so everything need not come into
your cv okay there are certain soft
things which you need to pick up also
uh
another thing is that
uh
you also need to have some very very
special friends okay special friends
means like
more than best friend i would say
let me give you a small example here
from my own life when i was an
undergraduate student once
i mean
i just fell ill
okay and fell in like it was like a
sudden illness i mean once i i got up in
the morning and then i just couldn't
raise my head from the bed
so what i did was i just called up my
friend who was in another hostel
actually because mind you this was
winter
there was practically no one in my own
hostel
and so i just called up this friend who
was in another hostel some distance away
this was very very early in the morning
in a winter
i just call him
please come without a single question
asked he got up and came in that morning
he didn't even ask what happened what do
you need nothing he just
heard me saying that please come he just
came
that's it and then he took me to the
hospital help me out so that's that okay
so you need to have that kind of special
friends who can answer to your phone
call at 4 am without any questions asked
all right
so uh
i'm almost at the end of my uh
of this little
advice piece
uh
finally i would like to just point out
one very important thing so i've started
our discussions from point number one uh
but
since um
both thermodynamics and the python
programming language are important to
engineering and science
as a mark of respect to both
thermodynamics and python i will put
this as number zero
and that is your health
none of the things that i have mentioned
earlier
is going to be of any use or any
applicability to you
if you do not maintain your health
okay i am no health expert myself but i
will tell you this that you should eat
properly and try to sleep
properly at least
i mean even if you're having nothing
special food no new i mean we all know
what hostel food is
but try to
eat regular hours okay that will i mean
automatically take care of a lot of
things if you eat regularly even if
nothing great food you're eating
and i know that engineering students and
science students they will invariably
sleep at unearthly hours
me advising you against that is not
going to change anything you will end up
doing those things
but still if possible
whatever weird hours you sleep try to be
regular even in that so your body will
have a certain
mechanism
in which it is comfortable so with these
pieces of advice i'll end this video i
wish you the very very best of luck so
all the best and i hope you have an
absolutely wonderful career ahead of you
thank you